>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Pam Jackson: So, good afternoon.
Thank you for joining us here
at our Books and Beyond talk.
I'm Pam Jackson, I'm director for
the Center for the Book and I'd
like to welcome you this
afternoon for a great conversation
that we're going to have.
Here at the Center for the
Book we care about and intend
on making a lasting, productive and
phenomenal difference in the world
of reading, promotion and literacy.
It's like what we care about,
what we're focused on,
what matters most to us.
So, we're glad that you're here
to join us in the conversations
that are ongoing about that.
We are part of the new National,
International Outreach unit
at the Library of Congress,
whose mission is
to share the diverse
vast rich collections
of the library outward and onward.
And as a Center for the Book we
have a number of partnerships
around the country with reading
promotion partners and a network
of state centers for the book.
Am I not -- yeah.
Well, I see a green light.
Can you hear me?
Volume. Let's see.
I'm surprised I'm not loud enough.
Yep. No, no volume control.
So, let me try this, is this better?
Little bit better.
All right, great.
So, let me just pick up where I left
off which was, oh, so part of NNIO,
so, National, International
Outreach at the Library.
We do -- I was starting to say
this, we have a national network
of state Centers for the Book,
that also include the District
of Columbia and the University
-- and the US Virgin Islands.
And the Center for the Book
administers the Library Congress
Literacy Awards Program, which
also has a network of organizations
that are award winning
for their best practices
in promoting literacy
around the world.
And we are honored and celebrated
a conference just this last week
with partners and friends from as
far away as Afghanistan and Brazil
and New Zealand and
Cambodia, were here to join us
in a conversation promoting
reading and literacy.
So, your presence here today
and your viewership online
of our webcast is an
exciting part and an extension
of the promotion partners
that we care about,
that we consider part
of our family in.
So, let me just mention a little
bit about what we're here to talk
about today, which
is an amazing author,
who's written about
an amazing woman.
And before I say a little bit
about more and introduce her I want
to mention for housekeeping --
a couple housekeeping purposes
and then I'll introduce our speaker,
I mentioned this is a webcast,
so we're filming for the website.
If you do participate in the
question and answer portion
of our program you will
be recorded and on tape,
so we're just giving you
the awareness of that.
We ask you to take a moment
and just check your devices,
your mobile devices that
the ringers are off,
so that we won't have disruption.
And another piece -- and
disrupt the webcasting.
Our taping of this author talk
is one of more than 250 we have
that are online and
available at read.gov.
We invite you to visit
that site as well.
With that being said,
let me actually talk
about our author and
our topic today.
So, the criteria for our
Books and Beyond talks is
that we are celebrating books
and authors who've done research
in the Library of Congress
collections or they're writing
about the Library of Congress.
And today's author
has done just that.
Louisa Thomas is here to
discuss her book, the --
Louisa, The Extraordinary
Life of Mrs. Adams.
And it's an interesting piece that's
a very comprehensive biography
of our own -- only, as I understand,
first born foreign born first lady.
Louisa Thomas is the author
has done a number of projects.
She's a journalist and an editor
and the author of "Conscience,
Two Soldiers, Two Pacifists,
One Family.
A test of will and
faith in World War I."
She is had her writings appear
in the New York Times, Vogue,
The Paris Review and elsewhere.
She's a contributor
to the New Yorker.
And what she's written
about is an interesting
and dynamic woman who's made a real
mark in the fabric of our nation.
And I consider our
author, herself, the same.
So, let's welcome Louisa Thomas.
[ Applause ]
>> Louisa Thomas: Thank you so much
for that introduction
and for having me here.
It's an honor to be here, especially
considering Louisa Katherine Adams
connection to this city and
to this spot in particular.
As I drove here I thought of what
Louisa must have seen when she drove
to Washington for the first
time, shortly after landing
in the United States in
1801 at the age of 26.
Her stage drove down
dusty turnpikes,
past a few scattered clusters of
dwellings, amid broken plaster.
The kilns from the construction
yet to be disassembled.
When she past the capital
it was very an idea.
Still headless without its dome.
There were cows and birds,
half built sandstone buildings
already beginning to crumble.
Tree stumps threaded the way, which
caused danger to her carriage.
"The area," she later wrote, "was
a scene of utter desolation."
It would become the place where
she found her greatest successes
and her most painful setbacks.
It would be the city where she
chose to live out her days and died,
home, such as she had one.
But it would take her a long
time to get to that place.
Her relationship to the
United States was as fraught
as the new nation's
relationship to itself.
She was born in London to a British
mother and an American father
and at the age of 9 in 1784,
just months after the revolution,
she was made a citizen of Maryland,
but that didn't mean
much to her then.
By the time she reached the
United States she'd already lived
in France and Prussia.
She crossed an ocean and mountains.
She'd already seen many things few
people over time could even imagine.
But her new home was to her the
strangest place she'd ever been.
"Quincy, what should I say
of my impressions of Quincy?"
she later wrote of her arrival.
"Had I stepped onto Noah's
Ark I could not have been more
utterly astonished."
Her introduction was
not exactly auspicious.
Abigail Adams, who once called
her a siren, found her frail
and vaguely foreign, a fine lady,
which was not something a good
New England housewife was supposed
to be.
For her part Louisa was
at first intimidated
by her resolutely cheerful
and industrious mother-in-law.
Bewildered by the local customs
and overwhelmed by her new duties,
she'd later say, "Where
was I supposed
to have learned to milk a cow?
At the card table in
the Prussian Court?"
As it happened, being a fine
lady with a canny political
and intelligence would help
her immensely in Washington
and the diplomatic world.
If not in the barnyard.
But the truth was, and I really want
to emphasize this, she was frail
and she was insecure and
she was far stronger though
and more resourceful
than she first appeared.
Let me tell you another
story about her.
In 1814 at a small post station 12
miles outside of St. Petersburg,
Louisa said goodbye to
her husband, John Quincy,
not knowing when she
would see him again.
There were tears on her cheek,
cheers of distress,
as well as grief.
John Quinsy was living Russia
to negotiate the treaty
that would end the war of 1812.
And leaving Louisa alone with
her 7 year old son Charles,
in a ruinously expensive city
where she did not speak the
language and had few friends.
She'd just lost a much
loved daughter
and she'd not seen her other
two young sons for 5 years.
Now, she was on her own.
It would have been hard for anyone,
but for Louisa the prospect
was really daunting.
Even in the best of times
Louisa often doubted herself.
She described herself as timid.
She called one of her
unpublished memoirs
"The Adventures of a Nobody."
Another was just, "The
Record of a Life."
At the end of the year John Quincy
wrote to Louisa and told her
to pack their things or sell
them and meet him in Paris.
No problem.
The trip was nearly 2000 miles
over the half thawed land,
devastated by the Napoleonic wars.
She and her tiny son,
armed with his toy sword,
were on the road for 40 days.
And in that time she was
robbed, warned not to continue,
told that one of her two
male servants, whom she hired
to protect her, had
a local reputation
as a quote, desperate villain."
She traveled over half
burnt, half empty villages,
over battlefields still
strewn with wreckage.
She listened to women tell her
stories of rampage and rape.
Halfway through she learned that
the man behind all this, Napoleon,
had escaped Alba and was
heading, as she was, toward Paris.
Men were mustering,
readying for war.
Her male servants fled in fear.
She, on the other hand,
pretended to be Napoleon's sister.
At one point her carriage
was surrounded by soldiers.
"Tear them out of the
carriage," they cried.
"Kill them."
It was in French, a language
she could understand.
"Long live Napoleon," she yelled,
and waved her handkerchief,
"Long live."
That was all in French,
but I'm not going to try.
She went on.
What was so remarkable to me
about that journey is not
only how daring it was.
It's also what she made
of it later in her life.
20 years later she wrote
and account of that trip.
She understood that it
was not only a good story,
but something that she could use
to illustrate something of herself.
Something of her fortitude,
her curiosity, her resiliency,
something of herself and
it was something she wrote
that she could use to
show what women could do.
She wanted to show there were not
-- I think her phrase was, "The --
struck by the imbecility that" --
something about the public was
always fancying women to have.
But she also wanted to show
that she was one who was.
Those were her words
and she underlined them.
That suggests that in her darker
moments she thought she would
be forgotten.
And for a long time she was.
When she was mentioned in accounts
of her more famous
relatives she was a footnote,
half dismissed as sickly and sad.
Some knew better.
John Adams called her
journals, which she sent to him,
unnecessary of life to me.
Her grandson, the great historian,
Henry Adams, was fascinated by her
and thought he might
publish some of her papers.
He copied hundreds of
pages and is possible
to see their influence
in his own work.
The first editor of the Adam's
papers, Lyman C. Butterfield,
once wrote, "In the entire span
of the Adam's dynasty no figure
is more central than the wife
of the second Adam's statesman,
and yet none is less
known or more elusive."
She was unknown because for
two centuries she was thought
to exist outside the
bounds of history.
Those chronicles of deeds and men.
She was elusive too, because she was
contradictory about her importance,
and her family's background,
denied her worth
and was quick to describe
her doubts.
Her character was quicksilver and
the roles she held were unofficial.
She was an American who was foreign
born, a first lady in a country
that was not quite
her own and a mother
who out lived all but
one of her children.
She was torn between cultural
ideals and strong instincts
that she could not ignore.
The idea that a woman should wonder
about her independent identity apart
from her husbands,
apart from her sons,
apart from her family was
hardly prevalent or desirable
in the tine in which she lived.
It could be painful.
But there was also a
kind of freedom in it.
The other members of the Adam's
family took their identity
and their duty for granted.
Facebook for the ages.
She could speak for herself.
It became her habit,
even her strategy
to define herself as
not like the Adams's.
And, yet, in some larger sense,
the Adams family helped instill
in Louisa what it helped
instill in the young Republic.
A concern for the value
of the individual,
a fascination with human nature
in its various forms and awareness
of selfish instincts, a suspicion
of power, a respect for traditions
and a willingness to scrutinize
people, especially ones self.
And it was in the letters she
exchanged with the Adams family
where she found her voice.
It was her voice that
first struck me.
As I read her letters I thought to
myself, "Who was this other Louisa?"
They were vivid, propulsive,
urgent, often hilarious.
She had an eye for the pompous
general, the charismatic politician,
the dynamics of Washington life,
of the battles in the capital
and in the parlor where
she once wrote,
"Ladies wars are always
fierce and hot."
There was nothing settled, nothing
cast in marbled or enshrined
in posterity about the people she
met and the events she witnessed.
She witnessed so much.
When John Quincy died some said in
his life once could find history
of the country's first half century.
Something like that
could be said of her.
She was born only months before
the start of the revolution.
The year she first arrived
in the United States federal
power passed peacefully
from the opposition, her
father-in-law, for the first time.
On the day that her daughter died
in St. Petersburg,
Moscow was set on fire.
When she died the United States
were only a few years away
from Civil War.
Part of the pleasure of writing
the book was seeing these events
through her amazing gimlet eyes.
She was born in 1775 in London.
Her father was a classic
crafty merchant
and her mother was vivacious,
charming, socially ambitious.
Her parents had secrets.
Some of which Louisa
may have sensed.
She spent the American
Revolution as a young child living
in a luxurious mansion in France and
when the war was over she returned
to London where she was
taught to be a lovely ornament
in the language of the day.
For the most part Louisa
was raised as young, pretty,
wealthy English girls were
raised, only she was told
to consider herself an American and
much more importantly, to marry one.
Her relationship with John
Quincy is central to this book.
It was sometimes passionate,
sometimes tender, sometimes fraught,
beginning with their courtship.
In 1798, when they wed, he made
it clear that he was committed
to his country and in marrying
her he was committing her too.
She tried it once to
reform and resisted.
After their wedding she and
John Quincy went to Berlin
where he was tasked with
negotiating a treaty
and she was negotiating a royal
court, representing a republic
who had never been in a republic.
When she reached the United States,
with its democratic pretentions,
she would find that navigating this
country was much more difficult
than learning how to
dance with the king.
It was harder because there
was no room to settle.
She lived in London, France, Berlin,
Russia, Washington, Boston, Quincy,
and travelled extensively.
She spent time in apartments,
hotels, houses, docas, cottages,
the White House, there were ships,
carriages, sleds, coaches, trains,
steamboats, it might
not be too much to say
that for long stretches she
lived in traveling cases.
She often felt that
she didn't belong.
This makes it easy and a
little tempting to dwell
on what makes her elusive.
But Mr. Butterfield was right
also to call her central.
She was a force.
Witty and charming and critical
to her husband's diplomatic
and political efforts.
Abroad she won favor
with kings and queens.
At home she sparred and bantered
with leading politicians.
She presided over weekly dinners
for senators and cabinet members
and dignitaries, giving them
the cover to talk politics
when politics were a dirty word.
She set up a kind of
campaign headquarters
in her parlor one summer
in Philadelphia.
And she had a series of
weekly parties called,
Tuesdays at Mrs. Adams, that made
her the dominate social figure
in Washington.
On the morning before one of these
parties, one of the biggest parties,
the newspapers all ran a
poem, every stanza ended ,
"All are gone to Mrs. Adams."
Her party was actually a pretty
brilliant political maneuver
in siphoning some of the
tension away from Andrew Jackson,
who had become the leading candidate
while her husband's fortunes
were lagging.
And it was actually
delightful downstairs
in the manuscript room there are
in several collections from people
of that time, there are copies
of the original invitation
for that event, which
was fun to find.
That was in 1824.
It was -- and it's also striking
that so many people saved it.
It was her campaign in
some ways more than his.
At a time of rising popular
sentiment and turmoil
within the political
establishment she understood
that people are governed by
emotions, as much as laws
and that politics are about people.
Their little passions
and prejudices,
their feelings of want and hope.
John Quincy did everything he
could to hide his feelings.
He even refused to campaign for the
presidency, because he did not want
to appear to beg for votes.
He lashed himself in his diary
for his failings, but outwardly,
as a son, Charles wrote,
"He wore an iron mask."
She understood something else,
a lesson painfully learned,
ambition could have terrible costs.
At just the moment John
Quincy came into the power
of the presidency she
felt most powerless.
She was isolated, felt
alone, they fought.
The children struggled, their
family began to fall apart.
When she and her husband returned
to Quincy she believed that had come
to live out their days
exhausted and grieving,
self-questioning, self-flagellating.
She thought she sacrificed
much too much.
But she was resilient and,
in fact, the Adams last
and greatest act had just begun.
When her husband became one of the
first great anti-slavery leaders
in Congress she wrestled
with what it meant
to be a woman, a wife, a self.
She thought about how to
have faith, what's so fine,
what to live for and why?
As fantastic as her adventures were,
the real story is of her inner life.
Her biography cannot be
told like her husbands.
It is a history of
feelings, as well as facts.
Of questions, as well as answers.
Of doubt, as well as certainty.
It is a record of a life.
It is a narrative of a journey
and it is the adventures,
not of a nobody, but of
an extraordinary woman.
And I would be happy to answer
any questions you all might have.
[ Applause ]
>> Louisa Thomas: Yes?
>> Audience Member: I wondered, what
kind of education did she receive
over in -- [inaudible] tutors
or something like that.
But, [inaudible] to hold
her own against the Adams.
She must have received
deplorable education.
>> Louisa Thomas: Well,
it's interesting,
this is actually something --
the questions about what kind
of education she received.
And this is something
that preoccupied her,
because she felt the
gulf in learning
between her and her husband.
She went to a boarding school
outside of London until she was 14.
Which was lead by a woman,
Elizabeth Carter, was very well read
and she had a very -- a couple
of very unusual teachers.
One of them was a woman who
she later described in one
of her memoirs as dressing
like a man, actually,
and who had received a
formal, classical education
as if she had been a boy.
She knew Greek and Latin
and introduced her to Milton
and Shakespeare and she, you know,
she was, Louisa was very proud
of the fact that when her
father gave her a shilling
when she was 11 she used it to
buy a Paradise Lost and a treaties
for self-knowledge, which was
a popular book at the time.
And, you know, and her letters
are just sprinkled with references
to Alexander Pope and, you
know, she was a great reader.
She also had another teacher
who was not her formal teacher,
but a reverend named John Hewitt,
who was actually a leading figure
in some of the countercultural
circles in London interestingly.
He was a very good friend
of people like John Keats,
he was actually the one that
mentored Mary Wollstonecraft,
and actually took Mary
Wollstonecraft's first book,
which was about the education of
young women, to his own publisher,
also by the name of
Johnson actually.
And got that published.
And he would later become
actually the Minister to the --
to some -- one of the royal family.
But and Louisa spent a lot of
time with him as a young girl
and she later wrote that he --
her quote was, "He
taught me early to think."
And that was actually pretty
unusual for a woman in that time.
In fact, Mary Wollstonecraft's
whole revolutionary idea was
that girls should be
taught to think.
This is like really
considered radicalism.
Feminist radicalism at the time.
Not obviously those
words were not used.
But that actually went into
abeyance once she got out of school,
mostly for financial reasons.
You know, she had a pretty
sad education, you know,
being taught to dance and
embroider and get married,
essentially and run a house.
And when she met John Quincy
she actually asked him
for a reading list.
She said, "I want to
close the gap between us."
And he laughed at her and that
was actually painful for her.
And he kind of criticized
her reading and that was --
I mean, that was one of
the issues between them.
Later on she would
just devour books.
And she wrote about them
sometimes, you know, Maria --
some of them are people we
don't know anymore, like,
Maria Edgeworth was very popular.
Some of them we do,
like Sir Walter Scott.
But, you know, she wrote
about, on several occasions,
she wrote about Lady Macbeth, you
know, sort of interesting people.
Hamlet, she wrote about her reading
and she tried to teach herself,
especially when her -- this
is much too long an answer,
but when her kids went to
college, went to Harvard,
she decided to sort of
study alongside them.
She tried to learn Latin,
she translated Plato --
Socrates, "Apology," from
the French, not the Greek.
But she was sending these
things to John Adams
and he was sort of,
"What are you doing?"
But it shows, it reflects
her real desire to learn.
Something that was apparent,
I think, as a young child
and then kind of re-flowered
in middle age.
Yeah.
>> Audience Member: I was curious.
What prompted your interest
to write about Louisa Adams?
>> Louisa Thomas: Well, I read some
of her letters while doing research
for someone else on a book and that,
you know, as I mentioned in my talk,
her voice was just totally unusual.
It was unlike any of the
other people I had read.
Especially a lot of the men, you
know, these kind of historical,
you know, Madison and Jeffersons.
They knew that they were writing for
their future biographers, you know,
they carefully copied their
letters, they, you know,
kind of left us well organized.
Archives are, messy archives, but
they left us things for posterity.
And her husband did the same.
She did not do that, you know.
Half her letters said, "Burn
this," at the bottom, you know.
But she was really kind of writing
for herself and for the people
that she was communicating with.
And there was a kind of
freedom to, not only her voice,
but also her observations, which was
absent in a lot of the things I saw.
And, so, it was so
exciting, actually,
to kind of encounter this
incredible human, you know,
and it's what can sometimes be sort
of, you know, calcified by myth and,
you know, even by the best
kind of research, you know,
somewhat distant, you know.
Her voice was like in her ear and
I couldn't really get rid of it.
And it actually I read
those letters in 2008.
So, that gives you some sense of
how I just couldn't shake them.
Yep.
>> Audience Member: Could
you talk a little bit
about her relationship
about John Adams?
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Louisa Thomas: Sure.
That was -- her -- the
question's about her relationship
with John Adams, her father-in-law.
And that was extremely close.
She had a much more complicated and
difficult relationship with Abigail,
but John was, as she wrote,
"A friend from the first
time, instant they met."
And he loved her.
He once said that marrying
Louisa was the best thing.
He told someone else that marrying
Louisa was the best thing John
Quincy had ever done.
This was actually when
he was president, so.
Yeah, I mean, they -- Louisa
had been sending Abigail kind
of diary letters, which was
pretty common at the time
and when Abigail died
she stopped writing
and like three weeks
later a letter arrives
from John Adams saying,
"Where are my letters?"
So, she picked it up and they had
a really wonderful correspondence
and she sort of stepped into
the role that John Adams seemed
to have wanted of the, you know,
strong intelligent woman whom
he could talk about everything
from politics to, you know,
what birds were chirping
outside his window.
Yeah, I know they had a wonderful
and warm relationship
through until he died.
Yep.
>> Audience Member: When Dolly
Madison died there was a great
[inaudible] outpouring of grief.
What kind of reaction in
the nation when Louisa died?
>> Louisa Thomas: It was actually --
the question is about what
happened when Louisa died.
And it was actually the first time
that both the House and Senate shut
down for her as a mark of
respect and to attend her funeral.
That was the first time that
had been done for a woman.
Her pallbearers were all the kind
of leading figures of the day.
And there was a great, you know,
the whole thing, parade, you know,
thunder, you know, cannons.
It's actually really interesting,
Charles Adams writes in his diary
about that day, about the funeral.
I don't know if there was the same
kind of public outpouring, you know,
outside of Washington for Louisa.
I think in some ways Louisa was more
of a controversial
figure than Dolly Madison.
I know that is true.
"Everybody loved Dolly",
as Louisa like to say,
with a somewhat fake
smile on her face.
Just as Dolly once wrote of her,
"I hear Mrs. Adams is
keeping up the dissipations."
As if Dolly hadn't been
quite the hostess herself.
So, the -- but, yeah, she was
loved by those who knew her,
but she had not been quite
as formidable a first lady.
She was more a social force before
and after John Quincy was president,
but not during the presidency.
But Charles wrote about
that day and, you know,
how overwhelming it had
been and how he was --
he had wanted something
actually private.
He'd originally thought maybe her
pallbearers should just be members
of the family and things like
that, and then he realized he had
to include all these people.
But the most striking
thing is that he wrote
about being amidst this
incredible public, you know,
big celebration of
his mother's life.
He said, you know, "I've
never felt more alone."
You know, just, it
was incredibly moving.
Yes.
>> Audience Member: I've forgotten
my history, was John Adams --
or John Quincy Adams,
was he a [inaudible]?
>> Louisa Thomas: Well, it's not
-- yeah, I'm going to say yes.
He was technically not the
rank of the ambassador,
we didn't have an ambassador
in those days.
He was Minister of
Planet Potentiary.
But we can call it ambassador.
Yes.
>> Audience Member:
Her religious life?
>> Louisa Thomas: Very
incredibly important to her
and increasingly so
as she grew older.
She was -- the question is
about her religious life.
And she was, I would say,
idiosyncratic in her
religious beliefs.
As she put it late in her life,
"I'm not so sure some people
don't think I'm heretic."
You know, she had gone to a convent
school when she was in France
and really was always
drawn to the --
and then had been an
Anglican growing up in London
and was always drawn
to the kind of ceremony
of the Roman Catholic Church.
She was never a Catholic, but she
was definitely more Episcopalian
than the Adams family was.
She did not like the snuffling
and note singing and,
you know, meetings.
She thought the fact that they
called the church service meetings
was terrible.
So, but she was sort of also
attended any service, you know.
When she was in Russia she was
going to Te Deum, you know, she was,
you know, she sort of saw it all.
And she became very very religious,
especially she had a lot of tragedy
in her life and when she was
older she wrote a lot about god.
I mean, she really almost, like,
would flip a switch, you know,
and start talking about
God and suffering
in kind of religious terms.
And I actually didn't really
understand some of her letters
until I was reading the psalms and
I realized that she was really kind
of borrowing a lot from some of
that metaphors and the language.
Yeah.
>> Louisa Thomas: Yeah?
>> Audience Member: Can you say
something more about the sources.
Are the letters here
or the Adams papers.
>> Louisa Thomas: Both.
I mean, the Adams papers in the
Mass Historical Society are --
would be this immense collection.
It's like 608 -- that might
not be the exact number,
but something like that -- reels
of microfilm, but there is a set
of that microfilm downstairs.
There's I think like 50 or
so of them around the world.
And they've also done a really
wonderful job of digitizing,
you know, most of their collection,
so all of John Quincy's diary
is not searchable online,
but searchable by date.
Which is amazing.
And then downstairs there's a
smaller Adams collection of papers.
And then there are also, you
know, she's friends with people
like the Thorntons, who was a
great architect at the time,
so they have collections.
Or Margaret Bayard Smith, I
think her papers are here.
Yeah. And, so, there's a lot of
like ancillary material here,
as well as some original
stuff downstairs.
Then, you know, you come across
things -- I mean, I was --
I had such a kind of
an amazing experience
at the Mass Historical Society
keeps a basically a database
of every Adams letter ever written
and it's coded by place
and everything.
And I came across a huge trove
that were not in that database
at the Historical Society in
Pennsylvania, because it was in --
she was very good friends
with someone
who later became a
Supreme Court Justice
and so it was a man
of some important.
And his papers were there
and there was a box marked --
that was called, "Letters
from Ladies."
And it had obviously not been
open since they were put in.
and there was just
this pile of letters
from Louisa Katherine
Adams right in there, so.
Yeah. Yep.
>> Audience Member: If you
were ever in a position
to actually interview her
personally, what would be a couple
of the questions you would ask her?
>> Louisa Thomas: That's not a
question I've ever gotten before,
so I'm not prepared
for this question.
But, I guess I would --
I'm not so sure, you
know, I'm not always --
I'm convinced that she's the most
reliable narrator of her own life,
so it would be interesting
to hear what she would say
on any number of subjects.
But, I think I would as her --
there were certain things I wanted
to know if she knew, you know?
I wanted to know if she
knew more about her mother
than she let on or her parents.
Because I think that does actually
change the story a little bit,
you know?
>> Audience Member: Why?
>> Louisa Thomas: Well, her parents
weren't married when she was born
and it's unclear whether
or not she knew that.
That actually became -- that was
actually brought up in the campaign,
in the reelection campaign.
Among -- there was a mudslinging.
You think elections today is bad.
And it was incredibly
painful to her and I wonder
if she knew whether
or not it was true.
You know, I want to -- she once
wrote that her mother was --
there was this misconception
that her mother was very --
was 15 when she first had her first
child with Louisa's sister, Nancy.
And this is basically under
girded a lot of the scholarship
that had been done about Louisa.
That Louisa must have known
that her mother was kind of --
and if she was 15 she was
probably poorly educated
or probably lower class and nothing
was known about her mother really.
And there was some sense that Louisa
was very insecure about her mother.
That's actually not true.
It turns out, you know, one of
the nice discoveries was be able
to actually find her mother's
birth records and things
like that in parish registers.
And since her mother was much --
and then reconstruct the map
of who her family was
and who her father was.
And her, you know, her mother
was pretty middle class.
Was 23, not 15.
You know, all these things.
I kind of want to know why she said
her mother was 21 when they went
to France, which would have made her
15 when they had their first child.
I have an actual theory which is
that Louisa was 21 when she went
to Prussia and I think
she was just --
when she was writing her own account
she was sort of putting herself
in her mother's place, or
putting her mother in her place.
That's -- No, no, no.
That's complete speculation
on my part.
That's what I'm saying.
That's not in the book, you
know, that's me standing up here
and coming up with a theory
that I can't ever confirm or --
but that's why I would
have to ask her, you know.
And I'm not sure she'd
tell me the truth.
So, but, yeah.
>> Audience Member: What was
her relationship to her family?
Did they support her and did
she communicate with the family?
>> Louisa Thomas: She was very
very close to her sisters,
they were her best -- and had the
typical siblings relationships,
fraught relationships with them too.
She was -- idolized her father.
And that's partly because,
I think, he had some trouble
that affected her and
she kind of built him
up in her mind in a
very defensive way.
But, yeah, I mean, she had a --
one of the ways in which she
kept her sense of herself intact,
you know, by being a not Adams,
was that she was Johnson, you know,
and she sort of held onto that
part of her a little bit tighter
than was common at the time.
And it's common for -- when you
marry into the Adams family it was
like a, pfft, you know,
it was all consuming.
And she kind of kept some distance
and partly that was by, you know,
she would sort of write things
like, "Well they, you know,
my father was a revolutionary
hero too."
You know, she sort of made a kind of
bigger deal out of her bona fides,
you know, than she
might have otherwise.
>> Audience Member: How
did she meet Quincy?
>> Louisa Thomas: Her father was
the American Counsel in London
and John Quincy -- and his
house was known to be a place,
it was very welcoming to Americans
who were visiting London, you know,
you come get your mail,
you talk business.
It was especially known
to be welcoming
to young American bachelors
because he had
so many pretty young daughters.
They would come to pick up their
mail and then stay for dinner
and then after dinner there
would be singing in the parlor
by the young soprano Louisa,
and the piano player Nancy
and Caroline played the harp.
And, so, it -- you know, there
house was very very social spot.
So, John Quincy came one day,
brought by John Trumbull,
Colonial Trumbull who painted
all those amazing scenes.
Who once had a thing
for Louisa himself.
And he kind of went away for
a month and then came back
and then came back night
after night after night.
And it's actually very
funny, he couldn't stay away
and he was suspicious of
pleasure, he was so, in some ways,
more puritan than, you know,
puritan and he would write
in his diary like, "This is
terrible, I have to get away,
this is so pleasurable,
what's going on?
I got to go."
Yep.
>> Audience Member: That
reminds me of John Wesley
when John Quincy was president
he embraced the philosophy
of John Wesley was, which
was to get up in the morning
and pour over your bible.
And in her journal she wrote that
the fact that their relationship,
because that was when they had their
most pleasant, amorous moments.
She was bitter towards John Wesley.
>> Louisa Thomas: Yes.
Absolutely.
>> Audience Member: Any questions?
Okay.
>> Pam Jackson: So let's
acknowledge Louisa Thomas.
[ Applause ]
>> Pam Jackson: Thank you so much
for being with us this afternoon.
We promote books and reading
at the Center for the Book,
because we believe they're the
best tools for joy and love
and laughter and for time travel.
Somebody, an author,
was here talking
about that a couple weeks back, that
we get to travel time and geography
and never leave our chair.
And you take us to exciting places
in your talk and in your book today,
so thank you for doing that.
We get a chance to be exposed
to cultures unlike our own
and hopefully broaden our minds
about who we are in the world
because we get to be with people
like you and the other Louisa.
So thank you for that.
I should mention too that the
books are for sale in the back,
so we welcome you to if you've not
already purchased your copy to do so
and to thank you for being here.
Again, we mentioned the
webcast recording of this talk
and many others are available online
at read.gov and we welcome you
to view those as well
and we welcome you back.
We're actually here
next week on November 10
for our next Book and Beyond talk.
We thank you for being here today.
What is the topic next week?
The designer of DC and I don't
have the name in front of me.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Yes, the
designing of DC, the building of DC,
shame on me for not
having it, right?
But the influence of
Spain and France
on the design and building of DC.
And I will have the talk
online, as a matter of fact,
so you can visit us at read.gov
and see our schedule there.
Thanks so much for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.